welcome back you're watching press tv
to help us understand the latest
developments in latin america we're now
joined by michael moynihan associate
editor of reason magazine
in washington d.c um up until a few
hours ago allegations and
accusations were clouding the meeting of
latin american leaders and now the hugs
and
smiling faces how did that happen
well i would say it's a bit of an
overstatement to say that there's hugs
and smiling faces but no you're
definitely right that the tenor
of the discussions has changed but you
know those uh those accusations still
stand
uh you know uh venezuela's hugo chavez
is not backing down he is saying that
we're gonna have peace now
but uh i don't think we were ever going
to have a war i mean this is typical
chavista hugo chavez saber rattling uh
you know he's he's not very popular at
home now for the first time and uh
in a long time but uh you know i i don't
there was never really a threat of war
uh so i think they're putting a smiley
face on it at the moment yeah
now how would you describe uh the role
of chavez and all this
uh he has certainly played a part hasn't
he
uh yeah he has most definitely played a
part uh in
the question is whether it was a
positive role or a malignant role
i mean i think the the obvious uh issue
and the obvious uh
question for a lot of people who are not
latin american experts by
any means uh tend to look at uh
a colombian incursion into a mile into
uh ecuador and they're wondering why
hugo chavez is getting all exercise
about this now the obvious thing for
latin america watchers is the fact that
chavez
is not very popular at home i mean
despite the fact that they have seven
percent
economic growth for the past uh two and
a half three years uh
people in venezuela are seeing major uh
food shortages at home because of price
controls
so i mean there's a lot of internal
domestic factors
that is uh that are driving chavez to uh
stick his nose into the business
of uh of his um his uh uh
ally raphael korea and uh also uh his
uh mortal and hated enemy alvaro aruba
so
yeah i mean chavez is using this for
domestic advantage and uh he's also
uh using it as a cudgel to uh beat the
colombians with you said you thought
there's not going to be a war but the
continuing military buildup near the
borders could that destabilize the
region
with all the simmering tension between
colombia and ecuador
yeah i mean i think it has destabilized
the region and the uh there's i mean a
lot of uh if you look at the european
union response un's response
there's obviously a tremendous amount of
concern because
you know you're right i mean there there
isn't i mean there's not going to be a
war at least
at this point uh but it is still very
anomalous and very strange for countries
to be lining up
uh troops on the border so i mean but i
mean now colombia
has a much larger army than venezuela
and a much larger and a much more
trained army than ecuador
so uh you know i don't think either of
these countries would
risk in military conflicts i mean that
that i think we can be pretty sure of at
the moment
but does it destabilize yes does it
destabilize more than
the the continent has been destabilized
already by
hugo chavez and by raphael korea and by
uh by abel morales and bolivia and uh
let's be honest also by uh alva
alvaro rebecca mike moynihan associate
editor of reason magazine in washington
dc thank you for talking to us